[Music]
the shika and the zonai two factions who
revolutionized the kingdom of Hyrule in
their own respective ways despite being
a fantasy world governed by swords and
Spears Hyrule has been no stranger to
the rise and fall of technologically
advanced groups or societies over the
course of its long history in Skyward
Sword the earliest game into chronology
we explored the remains of an elaborate
mining operation spearheaded by
autonomous robots both Minish Cap and
Twilight Princess introduced an advanced
civilization in the sky who left behind
various relics of their impressive
engineering skills however with the
passage of time these technical Marvels
would often disappear as if they never
existed and were essentially back to
Medieval Times again such is the case
with Hyrule in the era of the wild have
you ever seen one of those quote unquote
documentaries that try to argue that
human advancements in technology were
influenced by aliens well in the Zelda
Universe this is actually kind of
reality except instead of aliens it's
Sky furries the Legacy and influence of
the zonai in tear of the kingdom is very
similar to the ancient shika in breath
of the wild both factions were at the
Forefront of a technological revolution
in hyru both constructed shrines and
autonomous robots and in each case
something happened which caused their
technology to fade from memory only to
be Unearthed many years later the
similarities are undeniable however
these two groups lived tens of thousands
of years apart it's unlikely they ever
even interacted with each other and yet
's a number of overarching motifs which
are found in both cultures things that
are way too similar to be coincidental
like the Divine Beast helmets which are
almost a carbon copy of the helmets worn
by the ancient sages the motifs inside
teers of the Kingdom's four main
dungeons which are Zoni in origin and
clearly what inspired the design of the
Divine beasts the constellations found
inside the imprisoning chamber and on
shika architecture or the fact that the
shika shrines on the great Plateau are
in the exact same spot the zonai shrines
used to be back when the plateau served
as hyrule's main capital I don't think
it's a stretch or even a theory to say
that the zonai likely had a pretty big
influence on the shika the Zelda team
didn't exactly make a big secret out of
this however due to the inclusion of
time travel it's possible that these
influences go much further and the shika
may have even inspired themselves to
some degree so today let's explore the
connections between the zonai and the
shika and see if we can fill in some of
the missing time between the distant
past the less distant but still pretty
ancient past when the shika were at
their Peak and the present day when it
all came together to finally end the
conflict that started tens of thousands
of years ago so let's get into
[Music]
it I think it's only fitting that we
start by outlining some of the
established history creating a champion
presents a rough timeline of events
leading up to breath of the wild and
according to this chronology the kingdom
of Hyrule had practically been locked in
a Perpetual conflict with Ganondorf
Ganon this is of course referring to the
original Zelda Timeline where Ganon Was
Defeated many times only to return again
in some way shape or form it mentions
ganondorf's birth his first
transformation into his b-like alter ego
which he didn't do in tears of the
kingdom and it even mentions one of the
sages from acarina of time that being
Princess Ruto what follows is a
significant time Jump or Gap where
nothing is documented only for a sudden
Revolution to take place in which hyro
transformed into a highly Advanced
Society thanks to the shika and their
technology so right away there's a lot
of missing time here hyu went from a
medieval Kingdom locked in an endless
Skirmish with Ganon to a thriving
futuristic Society meanwhile Ganon
himself changed from a cunning
individual with a thirst for Conquest to
what is essentially a Mindless force of
nature a pure embodiment of chaos and
destruction now up until recently we
could have made the argument that the
distant past seen in tears of the
kingdom is simply a reimagining of the
original timeline however as most of you
know by now hidar Fuji bayashi the
series director presents the possibility
that it's not so much a reboot but more
so a reset that at some point during or
after the original timeline the hro we
once knew was essentially destroyed only
to be reestablished after the Zone I
arrived Nintendo has since even updated
the timeline on the official Japanese
Zelda website to include breath of the
wild and its sequel at the very end of
course there's the whole question of
which timeline branch do they follow up
on is it a convergence All That Jazz but
that's a topic for another time keeping
Fuji Bashi statements in mind mind it
stands the reason that the arrival of
the zonai took place somewhere between
the distant pasts I.E all the other
games and Hy ru's technological
Revolution sometime before the Calamity
of 10,000 years ago when the Guardians
Divine beasts and shika towers and
shrines were created this would explain
why hyu evolved so rapidly in the
technology department in the first place
unlike the shika Tech which was banned
by the King after the victory over Ganon
the zonai Machinery did not receive the
same treatment at least not that we're
aware of sure it did fade from memory at
some point but that's because most of it
is found in the sky and inside the
depths two places which became largely
inaccessible and forgotten about by most
but there's clear indications that not
all zitech was lost and in fact may have
been used as a blueprint by the shika
after having played tears of the Kingdom
it's become more and more obvious that
the shika from 10,000 years ago knew a
lot more than they L on in the previous
title as an example it's all but certain
that they knew about the existence of
the underworld most of the entrances to
the depths formed or became accessible
during the upheaval with the exception
of two the secret passage below hyu
Castle which had been kept hidden by the
royal family and the hole inside the
yiga clan Hideout Master Koga explains
that after falling down the hole in
breath of the wild he found himself in
this new alien environment and he's
basically been down here all this time
from here he and his fellow clan members
have been exploring the world below
Hyrule building base camps and
experimenting with the zon machines they
found down here the yea's obsession with
the zitech was quite interesting to see
and actually quite fitting after all
they are former shika a tribe known for
being fascinated by science and
technology so their Roots really shine
through here either way it shows that
the hole inside their Hideout was
already connected to the depths before
the events of Tears of the Kingdom's
opening which is significant because in
breath Wild's DLC it came to light that
the shika built some kind of mechanism
at the bottom of the hole one that
reveals a shika Shrine so yes it's all
but certain that the ancient shika knew
about the depths which means they must
have known about the zonai technology as
well as there's an abundance of it all
over the the world and it makes you
wonder what other Secrets they've been
keeping from the public for the past
Millennia if there's anything the
ancient shik were good at it's digging
they buried massive towers and shrines
deep below the Earth and in the most
obscure locations even those giant
columns that surround hyu Castle in
breath the wild which according to
Zelda's old diary were buried so deep
that even after years of excavations in
and around the castle the hens were
unable to locate them the shika also
focused their attention in the opposite
direction the Astro Observatory inside
Hu castle and the giant telescopes found
that the shik tech labs indicate that
they had a profound fascination with the
sky and the heavenly bodies and up until
now it was never really explained why
this was so important to them with the
introduction of the zonai a civilization
that originates from the sky this
mystery might be one step closer to
being solved perhaps the shika were
trying to establish contact with the
zonai or look for signs of their
presence or guidance in some way they
may have even succeeded at some point
but if they did they're not telling it's
implied that the zonai didn't go extend
they simply left for unexplained reasons
probably back to where they originally
came from and only raru and his sister
minu stayed behind on the surface where
together with the hens they would
establish the New Kingdom of Hyrule oh
and speaking of the hens one thing
that's interesting about the shika in
the era of the wild is that according to
the profile section they are classified
as hens this may seem trivial for those
who started their Zelda Journey with or
after breath the wild but in previous
games it wasn't entirely clear what the
shika are exactly whether they belong
belong to a different race altogether or
if they're just an offshoot of the hens
or as the name suggests a separate tribe
while they have always had pointy ears
like the hens they also possess some
unique traits that set them apart like
their iconic Crimson eyes and white hair
and the fact that they have an above
average lifespan but I guess now we know
that they are in fact hen in origin at
least the ones from breath the wild are
just a different breed of hen with their
own unique philosophy and traditions not
only are they more spiritual than the
average hen they are much more efficient
at keeping a record of historical events
for example they are the only faction in
Hyrule who are still in possession of
documented evidence of the Calamity from
10,000 years ago the only surviving
record that we know of in tears of the
Kingdom impa refers to Old shika
literature from kako Village that
documents the existence of the Dragon
tear as well as the secret back room
inside the Forgotten Temple which no one
else seems to know about so with that
said let's discuss what could have
happened following the imprisoning war
and how it led to hu's massive leap in
technology bear in mind that this
section is highly speculative since well
we're talking about at least 10,000
years of undocumented history
here it's worth pointing out that
although the shika have been present in
Hyrule since pretty much the beginning
for the majority of the Zelda Timeline
they've sort of been teetering on the
edge of Extinction many of them died
prior to the events of acarina of time
during the infamous hyuan civil war and
following the timeline split their
presence has been negligible ever since
with only a few descendants or in some
cases only their symbols showing up here
and there hence it was quite surprising
to see them pop up in such large numbers
in breath of the wild suddenly there's a
thriving Village full of them even more
if you also count the ancient monks and
the yiga there are more shika characters
in this era than in all other games
combined back in ru's time we saw gorons
RTO gudo and Zora but no representative
of the shika not even among the sages so
it's unclear if the tribe who would go
on to build the Divine beasts and the
towers and such were already established
in this era my guess is probably not
during my first playthrough I was
convinced that they would reveal that
the shika and the zonai are related by
blood somehow and that the fifth Sage
would end up being paa or maybe purra
especially since the shika were kind of
on the sideline in this game I think it
would have been a cool plot twist but
unfortunately that's not what the
writers ended up going with so here's a
scenario of what I think could have
happened let's say hypothetically that
Hyrule was indeed destroyed at some
point during or after the original Zelda
Timeline as Fuji bayashi suggests that
of course doesn't mean that there
weren't any survivors it's not like when
a kingdom and its monarchy collapses
everyone else goes with it it's clear
from some of the Back stories that there
were people living on the surface before
the zonai arrived it's just that it
wasn't a kingdom anymore at this point
and humans and the other surviving races
were most likely living segregated into
separate tribes and factions if anything
the existence of Sonia proves that the
royal family bloodline managed to
survive the collapse of old Hyrule so I
don't see why the same couldn't apply to
the shika as well history has taught us
that the people of Hyrule are extremely
resilient no matter how big of a
cataclysm strikes there's always those
who persist and manage to pass down
knowledge and traditions the Wind Waker
being a prime example of that as is
breath the wild anyway since the shika
are officially classified as hens it's
possible that among raru and Sonia's
many human followers there were some who
shared a blood connection to the shika
from old Hyrule and are basically the
ancestors of what would eventually
become the shika in the era of the wild
in one of the cut scenes we see a guy
who not only has white hair despite
looking relatively young but also
appears to have a different eye color
from the other soldiers it's kind of
hard to see if his eyes are actually red
but they're definitely not blue or green
which is by far the most dominant eye
color among hens even raru and his
sister have blue eyes when the zonai
came down from the heavens bringing with
them knowledge technology and magical
artifacts like the secret Stones they
were essentially revered as Gods by the
surface dwellers and from here we have a
pretty good idea of what happened next
The zonai Departed again at some point
save for raru and minu raru then marry
Sonia and a new kingdom is established
which with the exception of the gudo
most racists seem to have sworn falty to
what follows are the events we know from
tears of the Kingdom's memories
ganondorf's attack on the kingdom
Sonia's death and finally the
imprisoning war which ends in raru
sacrifice and Zelda's dronification from
this point history becomes open to
interpretation as there's not a whole
lot of information available there's
only a few things we know for sure the
zonai temple of time and parts of the
surrounding land were lifted up into the
heavens by the sages and along with it
the construct who safeguards the purad
hyru castle would be built on top of the
imprisoning chamber a map outlining the
location of Zelda's memories was created
and hidden away inside the Forgotten
temple tyo ruins was turned into a
memorial site for the sages and at some
point the great Plateau was completely
refurbished its walls were renovated and
brought in line with the more modern
high in stonework and a new Temple of
Time was erected in the same exact spot
where zonai equivalent once stood
there's also signs that for whatever
reason old zonai architecture on the
surface was also renovated and given a
new look proof of this can be found at
the zonai ruins in faren and most
notably at tobio's Hollow here we find
structures whose outer shell is made up
of the green zonai stonework we first
saw in breath the wild while its inner
core contains the gray Zoni Stone workor
we see in the Underworld and in the sky
it's not entirely clear who did this
when they did it and why but it's an
interesting detail either way I suspect
that following raru and Sonia's death
and Zelda's dronification there may have
been a sort of divide amongst the hen
population a divide between those who
wanted to start fresh and establish a
new culture and those who wanted to
continue the legacy of the zonai by
building upon it the former turned into
the conventional hens with a new
monarchy their fancy castles strongholds
and garrisons and the latter turned into
the shika who continued to experiment
and expand upon the knowledge of the
zonai particularly in the technology
department this divide probably happened
gradually over time and wasn't immediate
nor was it hostile in nature like with
the split between the shika and the yiga
at least not initially instead these
were simply two different philosophies
coexisting and working together the
foundation of hu Castle shows that its
construction was a collaborative effort
between the hens and the shika which is
evident from the Astro Observatory
located at the heart of the castle as
well as all the other shika related
activities like the five massive columns
which were part of an elaborate security
system obviously the hens would never
allow stuff like this to be built inside
their own Capital if there were tensions
between the two in my video about the
upheaval we talked about that upside
down pyramid located on the ceiling of
the imprisoning chamber which according
to the game's files is called a
purification unit we know for a fact
that this structure didn't exist yet
during raru sacrifice so it was most
definitely built sometime after the most
striking detail about the unit are the
constellations which are eily similar to
the ones on shika architecture and it's
probably the first sign of the emergence
of shika culture in this era as for its
main purpose I think the name kind of
speaks for itself purification is the
process of extra rating something from a
substance leaving you with something
else ever since breath the wild it's
been hinted that there's a connection
between malice Spirit energy or life
force and the blue ancient energy that
powers the shika technology for example
in addition to ancient energy the Divine
Beast also required the life force of a
pilot to stay operational and of course
it's been shown that malice can also
interface with the shika Tech which
makes sense if all three substances are
based on the same principle that being
life force or just force as it's known
in Japanese both rarus green energy and
ganon's Malice are seen moving up and
into the ceiling and while the green
energy sort of coils around it the
malice moves in a steady stream all the
way from ganondorf's Corpse straight
into the tip of the purification unit as
such the most obvious answer is that the
purification unit is somehow turning one
or both of these two substances into a
new compound which I think could very
well be ancient energy and this has
actually been a long running Theory as
early as 2019 Nintendo black crisis in
collaboration with zeltic proposed that
ganondorf's body May have been used as a
kind of fuel source ever since his
imprisonment which was not only a novel
idea for the time especially given how
little we knew about the sequel back
then but it actually has more Credence
now creating a champion explains that
the biggest pocket of ancient energy is
located below hyu Castle which is why
the castle has long served as ground
zero for the shika's experiments the
book also mentions a central control
unit that supplies power to many of the
shika structures across Hyrule it was
even used as a plot device in age of
Calamity where Ganon shuts down the
control unit causing the paa Towers to
lose power temporarily but we never saw
this device with our own eyes that is
unless the purification unit is the
central control unit it was never really
explained why the castle specifically
was such a hot spot for ancient energy
there were signs that there was
something peculiar about the castle
especially underneath it but without
further context we didn't really know
what to make of it the sequel however
ties everything together and allows for
a more solid Theory tears of the Kingdom
provides additional evidence that Spirit
energy and ancient energy are closely
related to each other because when you
upgrade the energy cells on your zonai
battery for a second time they change
from green to blue making them last
longer my personal take is that ancient
energy is a more refined more powerful
form of the green zone ey energy perhaps
made possible by adding purified malice
to the mix I think the shika realized
early on that the immense energy being
expelled from Ganondorf seal could be
harnessed instead of letting it go to
waste and so they built a device capable
of absorbing malice and removing
ganondorf's evil Essence from it
essentially turning hyu Castle into a
massive power plant even the art of
mummification the shika monks practiced
could very well have been the result of
them studying the process that preserves
ganondorf's body and found a way to
prolong their own lifespan for thousands
of years by essentially mimicking the
seal which if true is even more proof
that the ancient shika monks knew a
great deal more about hu's history than
they were willing to share in breath the
wild I do believe that the modern day
shika genuinely had no idea but the true
origin of ancient energy that knowledge
does seem to have been lost at some
point perhaps due to the king's
persecution of the shika which forced
them to abandon their research
altogether but before that I think the
shika knew exactly where their fuel was
coming from I mean by all accounts they
are the ones who engineered it in the
first place some may see the shika Tech
as inferior to that of the zonai because
of stuff like ultrahand which is
convenient for sure but I'd argue that
the opposite is true as impressive as
the zonai technology is nothing we see
in tears of the Kingdom holds a candle
to the marvels of engineering that are
the Divine beasts these behemoths are on
a whole different level compared to the
atom the zon were building and it only
makes sense since the shika had
thousands of years to improve upon the
zonai technology of course that doesn't
take away from the fact that the zonai
provided the building blocks the
blueprints that inspired the shika I
think inspiration is the key word here
it's obvious that the shika adapted a
lot of things from the zonai from the
design of the Divine beasts to their
power source heck even their symbols
look alike of course the shika ey symbol
has been around since before skywood
sword so it's difficult to tell if the
similarities are a coincidence or not
but either way it's yet another
interesting connection between the two
unfortunately it's impossible to know
all the things that happened during
holl's technological Golden Age there's
just too much undocumented history
between the end of the imprisoning war
and the Calamity of 10,000 years ago but
I'd like to imagine that the shika Tech
was initially used primarily for
convenience you know Transportation
automation robotic servant stuff like
that which is likely why the Highland
initially seemed content with letting
the shika go about their business but as
we all know there did come a time when
the hen royal family grew more and more
anxious about the stuff the shika were
doing which ultimately led to a complete
ban on all shika technology and I think
this all started the moment the shika
started turning their machines into
weapons there's no doubt that the
weaponized Chik attch played a crucial
role in the victory over Ganon however
it also exposed how powerful the shika
had truly become it's told that during
the conflict with Ganon one of the
Divine beasts managed to blow a hole
clean through an entire Mountain giving
Mount hebra its iconic look witnessing
the awesome destructive force of these
machines it's understandable that the
king would be a little worried about the
future of his kingdom I'm not taking
sides and claim that the persecution of
the shika was justified but I mean I do
see where the guy was coming from the
Divine beasts were like the equivalent
of the introduction of the atomic bomb
in this universe and the shika were the
ones holding the launch codes if misused
they could vaporize entire armies and
Villages and thus thousands of years of
innovation were thrown by the wayside
buried and forgotten until the next
Calamity and well the rest is
history
[Music]
one last thing I want to touch upon
before we move on to my final thoughts
is the possible effect time travel may
have had on the ancient past I can
easily see that Zelda bringing the purup
Hadad to the past with her could have
had somewhat of an effect on hyo's
history after all it's kind of like
bringing a smartphone back to before
smartphones were invented as such the
fact that the purad and the original
shika slate are suspiciously similar in
both design and functionality might not
be a coincidence meaning the shika could
have accidentally inspired their own
technology to some degree of course the
shika could not have reverse engineered
the pad because it was sent into the sky
shortly after Zelda's dronification and
from what we can tell it's been there
all this time however Zelda did give
minu the opportunity to study the purup
hat for a while she is portrayed as
someone who collects and preserves
knowledge her massive library is a
testament to that we don't really get a
clear picture where this library is
located but my best guess is that it was
somewhere inside ru's C Castle on the
great Plateau it was sort of like the
equivalent of hyu Castle in this age and
just like hyu Castle it only makes sense
that this is where they kept their
knowledge just to be sure I thoroughly
checked every inch of Dragon Head Island
The construct Factory and the spirit
Temple since these are all places that
are also connected to minu but there's
nothing that matches the library the
zonai castle is a bit of a mystery in
and of itself because unlike the zonai
Temple of Time the castle is nowhere to
be found in the present day not in the
sky not on the surface or in the
Underworld as far as I know it's the
only place from Zelda's memories we
never get to explore in game and thus
the most likely candidate for the
location of mino's Library we know the
castle wasn't destroyed during the
imprisoning war you can see it standing
in the background intact right before
Zelda turns into the light dragon so
where did it go well seeing as the walls
of the plateau were completely
refurbished I think the most likely
option is that it was simply taken down
by the hens at some point if this is
true it's also possible that the
knowledge kept in mino's library could
have been preserved before the building
was dismantled and among these many
books there could have been records of
minu study into the purad which the
shika could have used to build their own
we also know that at least some of the
survivors of the imprisoning war knew
about the pad's existence and even what
it looked like seeing as there's an
image of it carved into the map and on
the wall of the Forgotten Temple so did
the shika inspired themselves nobody
knows for sure but I do think it would
be a pretty amazing plot
point
as far as connections between the zonai
and the shikao there's a lot more to
cover like how the shrine of
Resurrection was built right below the
spot where ru's Castle once stood but
just like with the zonai and shika I
symbols it's hard to tell if some of
these are deliberate or just a
coincidence I do think there may have
been an attempt at a sort of cover up we
talked before about the zonai ruins on
the surface and how they seem to have
been refurbished to look different I'm
not sure what the intent behind it was
whether it was to obscure the history of
the zonai or if there was some other
mode but it is an interesting detail I
know some people believe that the shika
might be descendants of the zonai given
raru and min's white hair but personally
I'm not really convinced Zelda does seem
to have aoni blood connection since she
possesses both raru and Sonia's powers
and the ancient hero looks like he could
have been some sort of zonai hybrid but
I find it hard to believe that the same
goes for the shika as well in my mind
the shika had a more spiritual or
philosophical connection to the Zai
rather than a genetic one they clearly
paid a lot of tribute to their culture
and overall were much more more adamant
to preserve the zai's history which is
in Star contrast to the hens who seem to
have been more focused on rebranding
their culture but I'd love to hear your
thoughts on all of this so don't
hesitate to leave your theories on the
zonai and the shikai in the comments
below I'm sure there's stuff I missed so
maybe there's even more to this mystery
now before I take my leave I have kind
of a special announcement to make up
until now I haven't done anything with
the channel regarding merch and I
initially intended to keep it that way
no disrespect to other creators but
personally it somehow felt wrong to have
some third party crank out a couple of
t-shirts and mugs from an assembly line
in God knows which country aside from
taking a cut I would be barely involved
I mean I don't know how to make t-shirts
however it just so happens that over the
past year my fiance has gotten way into
crafting and smithing and she's pretty
darn good at it too so we figured maybe
that's something we could do for the
channel these are all made in house
which makes it a lot more personal now I
will be upfront and say these are not
your typical mass-produced Zelda jewelry
you can get from AliExpress for a couple
of bucks this is is all handcrafted from
real silver which means every piece is
unique but it also means they are
definitely not as cheap however if you
have the money to spare and enjoy Zelda
themed jewelry you can support our
household and my fiance's hobby by
picking one up for yourself we're also
in the process of creating monster maze
pins for those who you know actually
want to own something with my logo on it
these are going to be cheap because they
are 3D printed I did model it myself
they come from our 3D printer in our
workshop and are hand painted and
encased in resin by my fiance afterwards
I'll put a link to all of this stuff in
the description and in the pin comment
in case any of you are interested and
with that I have said all I wanted to
say thank you as always for your
continuous support and viewership and a
special thanks to Heather blue Ren vat
James Covenant and all my other patreons
and channel members that is all for now
and I hope to see you all next
[Music]
time
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]